[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where first and foremost shout out to
Isabella Taylor from the notification
squad thank you so much for reading the
bell and officially being the first on
the Golden Globes video now even though
this is technically a film theory every
once in a while I'll dip into the wild
and weird stuff that you see on YouTube
salad fingers don't hug me I'm scared
and today we welcome another member into
the hallowed halls of weird YouTube
channels that will haunt your dreams but
instead of me saying anything I'll just
let her introduce herself she's quite
good at it I'm poppy I'm poppy alright
alright enough we get it point taken in
case you haven't seen this channel
around and either pewds or finebros let
me introduce you to poppy an aspiring
singer who has both a VEVO channel for
her original songs and a personal
channel where she posts frequent short
videos of herself and you might think
that this sounds perfectly
straightforward and wonder why this
would ever ever merit a film Theory
instead of say I don't know a third part
of Doctor Who well it's because the
content of the videos on her personal
channel are a bit more than what they
appear sure she might inflate and
deflate a rabbit toy over and over again
or cryptically talk about what time it
is or just read the Bible straight from
the beginning for a solid 49 minutes and
at first glance you might be thinking
that Poppy's videos are just random for
the sake of being random there are
plenty of other channels on YouTube
guilty of exactly that but puppies
aren't I've gone through every one of
that puppies videos and there are a
bunch of them as well as all our social
feeds and websites and there is
definitely a much more sinister
narrative going on here hoppy and the
other people behind these videos most
notably their director named Titanic
Sinclair yes you heard me right his name
is Titanic Sinclair like the boat and
the author of the most famous muckraking
novel of all time the jungle Upton
Sinclair are using these videos to
comment on what it takes to be a pop
star in the modern age and I don't mean
struggling your way through the ranks
from humble beginnings I mean being
churned out by a cold corporate machine
and selling your soul
the Illuminati you heard that right
poppy equals Illuminati confirmed now
that might sound like a far-fetched
conclusion to draw but the evidence is
there so strap in everybody because the
road to hell is paved in pastel pinks
has a really catchy reggae beat that
occurs in four quick phases phase number
one innocent but sexual one of the first
things you'll notice about poppy is that
she appears very young but how old is
she really is she around 16 or maybe
she's just a young looking 20-something
it's hard to tell and the people behind
the channel are certainly interested in
keeping her age as secrets as poppy said
in an interview with racked comm quote I
don't want people to talk about how old
I am
I want to talk about what I'm making
either way the clues to Poppy's youth
are everywhere in her early videos her
very first video shows her eating cotton
candy in another she's playing he loves
me he loves me not with a flower yet
another shows her hula hooping in the
name of her first extended play is
called a bubble bath these choices are
clearly no accident because when asked
in an interview to describe her style in
three words
poppy states fire me kawaii child Barbie
explains the pink clothes and blonde
hair and kawaii the Japanese concept of
cuteness exemplified by things like
Hello Kitty it's also pretty obvious one
look at her music video for money and
you see that Japanese aesthetic
everywhere but child is the important
one because it connects her to so many
young blond pop stars that we've seen
over the past 1 years for comparison
consider Britney Spears we're all
probably somewhat familiar with 21st
century Britney the one who wore a snake
to the VMAs made out with Madonna and
shaved her head but I'm sure that those
of you who can't tell a jennxpenn from
an RCA beauty can also remember late 90s
Britney as well when she first hit the
scene in the video for her first major
hit baby one more time Spears his
teenage niece is on blatant display
through her Catholic schoolgirl outfit
which of course comes with plenty of
sexual ization on its own I mean I've
been invited to Catholic school dances
before and I have seen some pretty wild
things at them but those moves that
Britney's doing aren't leaving any room
for Jesus known those early days she was
an undeniable sex symbol
but in interviews would outright deny
its telling Esquire in 2003 that quotes
look if you want me to be some kind of
sex thing That's not me
are you sure Britney because you said
this to a magazine that ran pictures
like this of her next to the very same
interview yeah cuz all the innocent
girls I know are doing photo shoots
topless pulling down their panties and
covering up their private parts with
giant strands of pearls what did you
think those pictures were for it's not
sexual
it's just artwork dear Britney when the
lyrics to your big song outright say I'm
not that innocent forgive people for
being a little skeptical when you say
that you are so in a sense that is all
I'm saying but back to 2017 it's hard to
deny that poppy is drawing some
parallels here just compare this still
of poppy from the video where she
introduces herself to the cover of
Britney Spears's first album poppy also
expresses the same kind of aversion to
sexuality as early era Britney did
Oh bid in subtler ways take a moment
from the video for poppies biggest
single lowlife she's seated at a table
with the devil [ __ ] on that one later
who peels a banana puts it in his mouth
and doesn't start to eat it that sir is
a choking hazard mr. Satan didn't anyone
ever tell you to chew your food sure we
don't see anything particularly graphic
going on here the puppies reaction tells
us pretty much everything that we need
to know sex is not a part of poppy or
her message but the companies that
manage publicize and basically create
pop stars don't care what your message
is in the words of another pop star pink
and her song don't let me get me quotes
Ellie told me you'll be a pop star all
you have to change is everything you are
they want their stars to be sexually
appealing because it gets them attention
and helps them sell to adults while
still staying a knock you enough that
parents don't find them too harmful for
the younger fans and if they're able to
pull off this balancing act that leads
them to phase two dolla dolla bills
admittedly this is the most
self-explanatory of the phases but it's
one that the creators of the poppy
channel definitely want to acknowledge
in their story the first indication of
money that we get is in the video I made
five hundred dollars in which poppy
gleefully examines and counts a stack of
five 100
Bill's she's received oh she earned that
money isn't entirely clear though
perhaps it's the result of the video
titled tied commercial in which papi
declares her love for tide and talks
about how much better her life is as a
result of the detergent but even more
egregious than that is the sum money
which shamelessly promotes materialism
with lyrics lights we can draw parallels
to pop music here but it's pretty
obvious with fame comes money but of
course with fame and money there comes
some drawbacks and that takes us to
phase 3 losing control of your message
if there's one way to make your fanbase
turn on you it's becoming a hashtag
sellout once a celebrity gets hot their
list of responsibilities goes way beyond
just making music at one point Lady Gaga
considered quitting music altogether
citing that she was unhappy with a
variety of things but especially being
used to make other people money by doing
things like selling fragrances are
standing around taking pictures when she
stopped doing those things she says she
remembered who she was as though taking
away everything behind the scenes
restored her individuality
similarly there are outside forces that
try to control what poppy has to say in
a lot of her videos in low life the
first music video I talked about earlier
we see men in suits and breathing masks
and wheelchairs the men behind the
scenes pulling the strings and trying to
get coffee to sell out the devil and his
um banana poppy in this video is able to
reject their control as shown by her
shoving them off stage but fast-forward
to more recent videos and this tide has
started to change in the video titled
jurt poppy is holding a t-shirt
containing her lyric if money can't buy
happiness then why is it so fabulous
poppy looks off-camera and asks what do
you want me to say the answer we get is
garbled and mechanical
but if you alter the pitch using audio
manipulation tools you get this just
read what's on the shirt
at which point papi reads the slogan
later in the video the voice tells papi
to tell the people to buy the t-shirt
[Music]
and she complies again this represents a
time recently after a pop star has
become famous and is being pushed around
to do and say and promote everything
that other people want in a more recent
video called
I'm not lying to you we get another
cryptic message from a skull that speaks
to papi in Reverse decoded it says but I
like before this time papi doesn't
follow instructions claiming that I used
to be more honest but now they won't let
me in fact papi makes a lot of
references to an unseen but powerful
they in many of her videos so who are
they are they the businessmen who we saw
on set with her well yes but it's also
far more dangerous than that and here's
where things start to go off the rails
in Japan we get the typical papi s
statements like what is a difference
between Hollywood in Japan and will you
come to Japan with me but towards the
end of the video the tone shifts as papi
urgently says to the camera don't tell
them I'm here I need to escape they
don't want me to go and then the video
cuts out it's not just that papi is
unhappy with her music career it's that
she fears she's in danger and that's
because she's a product of phase 4 the
Illuminati
yep the same group that causes videos to
have more likes than views and is
single-handedly keeping halflife3 off
the market is also keeping papi under
their collective thumb okay so seriously
this may feel like it's coming out of
left field but let me explain those who
believe in the Illuminati which is
according to theories an all-powerful
secret society that controls politics
and media and also occasionally
practices in the occult and brainwashing
believe that many of the most famous pop
stars in history are members Britney
Spears
a Christina Aguilera Lady Gaga Taylor
which Beyonce double-check and
triple-check
so if poppy is truly the tale of the
modern female pop idol then the
Illuminati being involved actually makes
a lot of sense
well how can you tell if someone's in
the Illuminati those of you whose heads
aren't wrapped in tin foil might be
wondering and there are essentially two
different qualifications one the person
must be famous rich and/or influential
and two they use the Illuminati symbols
since as this very scholarly looking
website puts it the Illuminati loves
taunting the profane that's a normal non
Illuminati people by putting their
symbols in plain sight for all to see
there are a lot of these symbols but
some of the most prominent include
things like a single eye also known as
the all-seeing eye or the Eye of
Providence triangles or pyramids skulls
and any other satanic images or symbols
like the number 666 and you don't have
to look very far to come across all of
these in Poppy's videos for a very
prominent triangle symbol look no
further than Poppy's video entitled
membership ring which simply features a
triangular ring and some dramatic music
of course the fact that it's even called
a membership ring is pretty telling as
it would seem to indicate that Poppy's
membership is in the Illuminati or
remember that video with the skull from
earlier well not only is poppy talking
to an Illuminati symbol but that symbol
is speaking to her band there are tons
of theories about satanic messages being
hidden in famous songs that are revealed
when they're played girl so keep a
listen for that and Poppy's next music
track next there are the eyes and boy is
the Illuminati watching in Poppy's
videos some are obvious like this still
from Poppy's video for money others are
a bit more subtle like a dress that she
wore to the iHeartRadio Music Awards
that's covered in eyeballs or in this
moment from one of her early videos in
which he puts her eye behind a hole in a
doughnut and if you're still not
convinced here's the bombshell if you go
to Poppy's homepage I'm poppy calm and
view the stores
just take a look at what comes up at the
top of the page that my friends is the
eye of Providence with the subtitle
poppy knows all just they're written
into the code not doing anything on the
webpage but hidden just beneath the
surface for theorists like us to find
damn you Illuminati taunting me with
your imagery I as a lonely profaned are
sold I don't know what what feeling is
this supposed to evoke in me jealous
beleaguered feel so beleaguered so
obviously there's plenty of Illuminati
imagery hidden throughout all of this
but that brings us to the occult symbols
and references again some are obvious
and some are less so of course we've got
the devil as the main character in
Poppy's video for low life but also
throughout that video we see poppy in a
very specific pose seated in a chair
with one arm pointed up and the other
arm pointed downward her fingers in a
very specific position this is a clear
reference to Baphomet a demon allegedly
worshiped by the Illuminati in various
other secret societies that allows them
to harness the powers of heaven and hell
even the seemingly random products that
poppy quote-unquote endorses have a
satanic connection Poppy's most recent
product video promotes both Doritos and
Monster energy drink
Doritos could be construed as Illuminati
symbols here both because they're
triangular and because puppy awkwardly
holds one over her eye for a moment
again creating the Eye of Providence as
for Monster Energy Drink there are some
who claimed that the drink is a symbol
for Satan and we're not just talking
about the taste
[Music]
I'll be here all week actually monster
energy drinks alright the logo for
monster is an M made up of three lines
which each bear a decent resemblance in
the Hebrew letter volve or six put the
three together in bingo the mark of the
beast' vah vah vah the monster six six
six tell you what I'm never looking at
Monster energy drink the same way again
but there's another element here that I
haven't addressed puppy isn't just a
cute singer under the thumb of the
Illuminati there's a lot of evidence in
these videos pointing to poppy being a
computer program created by the
Illuminati the video transmission shows
puppies personalities speaking through a
computer which in and of itself wouldn't
mean a whole lot but in videos like they
have taken control it's like she's
literally upgrading her software to have
new lines and emotions poppy loves you
and will always love you even the title
of they have taken control shows that
Poppy's personality is no longer her own
add to this the fact that in real life
the girl who plays poppy refers to poppy
and the third person like another person
or personality but what really gives it
away is one of her latest videos some
people a video that prompted me to
literally rewrite this whole episodes
conclusion right before he finished
editing it because in it she makes her
usual general statements about different
types of people there's tall people
there are short people blah blah blah
but it's the last statements of this
video that confirm her as something not
quite human she says some people add
skin then some people are made of
plastic before turning to the camera and
saying it's a bit to be a human being
that turn to the camera tells us
everything that we need to know it's the
director's way of signaling to the
audience that poppy isn't what she says
she is but another point of evidence
supporting all of this is that if one
poppy steps out of line it appears as
though she gets replaced by another one
consider the video titled Ono which
features poppy staring at the camera
before a second identical poppy appears
and the first starts to bleed from her
mouth it's a continuation of 10 episodes
earlier titled am i okay a largely non
important episode in the series until
the final frames which
her nose bleeding it says though papi is
deteriorating falling apart and new
Papi's are having to take her place in
fact it's probably papi getting replaced
that's caused the other characters in
the series a skeleton a plant and
Charlotte the mannequin to have this
conversation oh she definitely changed
see I told you we would he made she
didn't change and it's worth noting that
this illuminati programming doesn't just
apply to the blonde girl that we know as
papi it applies to us to involve step
one and step two
we're instructed to look into the
computer as digital sound effects play
in the background and papi encourages us
to keep going it says though by watching
this video we're the ones getting
reprogrammed we're the ones getting
brainwashed because in the end that's
what Papi's true purpose is here she's
not just some other young aspiring pop
singer she's the embodiment of all the
conspiracy theorists fears online
another pop star and media icon
manufactured by the Illuminati to
distract us with catchy songs and bland
phrases a means of keeping us normal
folk in line distracted with consumerism
fashion monster energy drink tide
detergent blissfully ignorant of the
real things that matter the Illuminati's
continued dominance over world power now
am i arguing that poppy and titanic
sinclair believe in all these things no
not at all poppy is a channel that wants
to satirically portray elements of the
life of a pop star from the dehumanizing
to the downright bizarre and hey if they
get popular along the way from people
like us and read it theorizing about
them well that's a weird twist isn't it
the music is pretty darn catchy I've
been finding myself watching more and
more of my every day it's one of my
favorite channels on YouTube I put in
every single day to our videos every
poppy upload that I see in my
notification
one that I watch sorry sorry I got
distracted there for a second in the
meantime remember that's just a puppy a
puppy in case you were wondering no
don't worry these videos aren't products
of the Illuminati to keep you distracted
from their continued dominance either
why would you think something like that
[Music]
watch more subscribe watch more
subscribe watch more subscribe watch
more